went to europe to be with her fiance and
in search of something better
but the migrant route which has ruined
so many lives in recent years
has ruined some more
this is where she grew up surrounded by
family on a small street in the kurdish
mountain town of solan
in the gentle autumn sun her father and
brother sit outside her childhood house
supported by neighbours and relatives
who come to sit quietly with them
[Music]
[Music]
mohammed hugged his sister goodbye at
herbal airport and never saw her again
this is his final memory of her
[Music]
she was looking forward to arranging
their wedding when she reunited with her
fiance in the uk
you love each other so much
love birds
love their just i never seen anyone like
them i used to tell my husband look at
him
buy me roses like him
just like that and they loved each other
so respectful to each other she even
didn't tell her husband that she was
going this way her husband was trying to
find a better way so what she does
before she goes on the ship she takes a
picture i'm coming to you makes a
surprise for her husband she was so
reminding they loved each other so so
much
on wednesday after months apart he was
excitedly following her progress across
the channel
halfway across the signal just stopped
the politics of europe's migrant crisis
is barely mentioned here
[Music]
there is no anger no blame just
inconsolable despair
[Music]
alice debunked sky news in soren iraqi
kurdistan